you visited my house not too long ago
while I was out of town you went to my
house is that right yes I didn't break
into Conan's house right I was an
invited guest of your wife my wife I
left town to take my kids on a camping
trip and the minute I'm out the door my
wife calls up all these cool women and
says let's have a ladies night yeah we
had like white girls would be a ladies
night when I'm there I'm a perv I just
want to watch in the district
yeah was so much it was so much fun we
your wife Liza I mean I used to intern
at your show back in New York when I was
19 but it's right we largely that was I
was just terrified of you and I did
never fight of me I think of myself as
such a friendly figure do you you are
but at the time right yeah and took the
lives and I became friends and I came
over to your house and it was really
exciting and kind of it was a little bit
better that you weren't there I kind of
think because I felt and everyone always
says that whenever I'm not around people
say hey it was better that you I could
really I'm kind of a nosy person I could
just like kind of go through your stuff
a little bit more wait you went through
my stuff first of went there it was
wonderful it was wonderful time I had
like 11 bottles of your wine we would
like that yeah
Coenen brand wine I make that myself
having never been there I think you have
an idea of what Conan O'Brien's house is
gonna be like and then I found it that
it largely wasn't the Kay it's like what
preconceived notions did you have about
my house that will tell you a lot about
what you think of me well I thought that
you would have you know you're a very
tall guy that you'd have this like long
enormous huge bed and I thought that
maybe there wouldn't be like like pee
and all times
not that many windows maybe not that
many windows your fair here the Sun
fight he still he still dwells
above-ground monastic Castle normal
that's very nice and you had a good time
I got got wasted hung out that's the
sense I got everybody I came back and my
wife everybody had kind of a red wine
hangover it was really it was very fun a
lot of stuff was missing my Gandalf bed
is gone
you